[Music]
donovan
you are a professional wrestler is that
right yes okay
now help me because i know of a type of
professional wrestler
that has a character and i don't know
are you a professional wrestler who's
really wrestling and using wrestling
moves and it's not that fun to watch or
are you a
a wrestler who's also kind of a
performer and has a
a character i am a character um
actually i have a picture if you want to
see it it's uh oh
my god okay well we are a podcast so i'm
going to describe it yeah
uh you're sort of demonic looking you
you just showed me a picture of
uh what looked like a very fierce evil
demonic
wrestler yes so i go by the moniker very
nice very evil
because nobody likes somebody who's too
evil so i introduced the
nice part of it so then they buy into it
i can trick them okay
very nice very evil often i get
described if uh
somebody a demon possessed you actually
oh a demon possessed me if conan o'brien
was possessed by a demon that's what it
gets described as because i'm heavily
influenced by you rather than other
wrestlers
yes you mean of the wrestlers i'm the
one that's influenced you the most
yes yes of course that's fantastic um
[Laughter]
describe then a demonic conan o'brien
as a wrestling character what what are
you using some of my
moves is it my attitude uh does your
character have uh
you know sort of little beady eyes and
thin lips and sharp cheekbones
yes yeah i don't have the height but i
have uh i
utilize so i pour teeth in my opponent's
mouth
uh to disorient them pouring what in
their mouth
human teeth you pour human teeth into
the mouth amazing
i love how that's people see that and go
oh that is so conan
that is no no no it's just i think it's
the presentation because i
i take a lot of like simpsons references
and
references from you and just uh 80s
horror movies
and i pull it all together because these
are the things that i like
so i included it into the character
because wrestling should be fun yes
wrestling's saying
it shouldn't be working yeah no no uh so
um okay your one of your standard moves
is to pour
loose teeth into the mouth of your
opponent to
confuse and disorient them what are some
of your other moves
kick him right in the mouth i have the
go to sleep which i call the good night
housing
um my wrestling name is dan hausen and i
add houzz into everything to make it all
about me
that's very cody yeah okay that's very
nice matt yeah
i love that you just add a house into
things so it's so good night housing is
like a good night move
yes and i pop them up off my shoulders
and i need them in the face
okay well you need them in the face
house the face
yes exactly sorry uh like if if i were
talking to you i'd call you conan
housing i had house into the end of
edinburgh uh-huh uh-huh
uh this is fantastic uh you're i'm
delighted by you
you're i'm delighted by this foolishness
and
uh that you've like me dedicated your
life to
absolute idiocy